36 87 por ciento de los votos ese fue el
resultado que obtuvo aquí en a niño en
el candidato de la francia y sumisa de
la izquierda yo me lanzo en la primera
vuelta de las presidenciales ninguna
sorpresa ya que esta ciudad vota
tradicionalmente hacia la izquierda sin
embargo se encuentra en un departamento
la bucles que es un feudo histórico
también de la extrema derecha por eso
eligió avignon la candidata de extrema
derecha marine lepén para realizar uno
de sus dos actos entre las dos vueltas
de la elección presidencial preguntamos
a los locales qué efecto tuvo la
presentación de marín lópez anoche yo no
soy racista soy argelino ella dice cosas
que son verdaderas lo que quiero decir
con esto es que no me da miedo
hay demasiada inseguridad en los barrios
mujeres que son asaltadas incluso aquí
en avignon a veces vemos locuras gente
que no tiene papeles gente que pide
dinero con niños de 8 meses en sus
cochecitos en los semáforos todo eso
tiene que pararse frente a una vertiente
de movimiento fascista
por lo que creo que hay que tener
cuidado a veces prepara política estoy
desesperada por la política voy a votar
el domingo pero creo que voy a votar en
blanco porque me niego a votar en contra
de un candidato
senior en el acto de anoche imaginen lo
que entra todo de seguir entregando
confianza a los franceses mostrar que ha
cambiado se presentó como la candidata
de la libertad de la democracia de la
unidad de la diversidad e incluso de las
mujeres y como la opción para los
patriotas de izquierda y de derecha
llamó incluso a los abstencionistas a ir
a votar dio o no resultado este discurso
lo sabremos el próximo 24 de abril